this post is going to help every single  person  who's building a business or a company  you may think this is a Jets post and  yes there's a little bit of a humble  brag that finally my jets in 41 minutes  got their [ __ ] going because these two  players are going to dominate for the  next decade but really it's a business  post a lot of you were going into 2023.  some of you are going to have to cut  staff some of you are going to be hiring  there's going to be a lot of turmoil in  this economy that we're in and the  reality is a couple of good decisions  can change everything over the last  several years I've made many good  decisions at Boehner X and Leadership  has absolutely had a massive impact on  growing our business the Jets in 41  minutes made two very good choices in  their world the draft in your world it's  hiring or promoting making one two three  really good decisions about human beings  in 2023 is going to unlock growth not  the reverse